[Musica]
sì qui si procurerà da d'ora suo ultimo
secs 3 ma schiacciate volatile the loom
cuoco e ritmi summa vis longevo e volare
am proibirà liqui chen sesso stare quei
posse altero truffate ari senin su mass
cohen eccessi
cosa ci vuole dire lucrezio con questi
stupendi e sonori esametri tratti dal
suo poema sulla natura
traduce in versi il ragionamento di un
grande filosofo della magna grecia
archita da taranto
vissuto intorno al quinto secolo avanti
cristo
partita si era posto un problema che ci
assilla dall'antichità e che tuttora
attuale come dimostra il tema di questa
serata è il confine
archita si chiedeva se l'universo avesse
un confine
oppure si estendesse all'infinito
ecco sul ragionamento che giunge si
giunge a noi attraverso i versi di
lucrezio se qualcuno si spinge fino alle
rive estreme e scagliasse un dardo
volante ritiene che questo ritieni che
questo vibrato con tutte le forze
raggiunga al bersaglio e voli oltre
lontano oppure che qualcosa gli si
opponga e divieti l'andare devi per
forza mettere o una o l'altra ipotesi
lucrezio continua e conclude qui il telo
delinque fiat che avverrà dunque del
dardo se poi se prosegue indisturbato
l'universo non ha confini ma se trova un
ostacolo e rimbalza indietro significa
che qualcosa c'è
oltre i confini e allora conclude
lucrezio con arkitano scomposti
consistere finis non potremo mai trovare
il confine dell'universo
nel passato i commentatori di lucrezio e
di archita hanno interpretato questo
ragionamento come la dimostrazione che
l'universo fosse infinito ma io credo
che questa conclusione
semplice quasi banale
non renda merito alla cupezza del
pensiero del filosofo greco e oggi anche
alla luce di quanto ci ha insegnato la
cosmologia dovremmo piuttosto
interpretare questo ragionamento come
l'impossibilità
di decidere se l'universo sia finito o
infinito
cosa ci dice infatti oggi la cosmologia
beh innanzitutto la cosmologia che è la
scienza di tutta la realtà fisica
si basa per procedere per progredire
nella conoscenza del metodo scientifico
moderno inaugurato da galilei e il
metodo scientifico di galilei ha come
sua come suo postulato quello di
rinunciare a tentar l'essenza come
diceva galilei la scienza moderna
rinuncia a indagare la natura ultima
della realtà ma si limita a studiare le
relazioni tra i fenomeni
relazioni tra i fenomeni misurabili che
avvengono nello spazio e nel tempo
spazio e tempo
due entità due forme pure della nostra
sensibilità che da sempre ci interrogano
sulla loro natura e sulla nostra
relazione con loro con lo spazio e con
il tempo senza spazio senza tempo non
potremmo definire i confini
e dopo lucrezio e archita molti filosofi
hanno indagato incessantemente la natura
di queste due entità finché
poco più di cento anni fa un'altra mente
eccelsa albert einstein
ci ha costretti a modificare
radicalmente quanto avevamo ereditato
dalla scienza e dalla filosofia dei
secoli scorsi lo spazio il tempo non
sono più assoluti non sono più lo spazio
non è più un contenitore
indifferente a quanto contiene e tempo
non scorre ugualmente dappertutto
il contenuto dello spazio e del tempo
la materia
i corpi materiali modificano la
struttura geometrica dello spazio e
modificano anche lo scorrere del tempo
un concetto totalmente nuovo di spazio
tempo difficile da comprendere ma che
ormai è quello che dobbiamo accettare
con questo concetto nuovo di spazio
tempo diventa molto più problematico
come vedremo definire un confine
dell'universo e io credo che se archita
lucrezio tornassero in vita oggi
gioirebbero nel vedere come le loro
intuizioni di secoli fa
sono confermate in maniera così
drammatica dalla scienza moderna
ma si meraviglierebbe rowe ancor di più
e questo dovrebbe meravigliare anche noi
tutti constat nel constatare che questo
nuovo concetto di spazio tempo e dico
spazio tempo perché lo spazio il tempo
non possono più essere considerati
separati uno dall'altro ma formano un
continuo questo nuovo concetto quando
viene applicato alla totalità della
realtà fisica quindi all'universo né di
svela la sua caratteristica principale
che era rimasta nascosta per secoli e
cioè il fatto che l'universo evolve a
una storia che si dipana da quasi 14
miliardi di anni passando attraverso
fasi diversissime tra loro e aumentando
sempre più la complessità
finché dopo appunto 14 miliardi di anni
in un minuscolo sperduto pianeta
insignificante di fronte alla maestosità
dell'universo è emersa la vita biologica
e la coscienza
la cosmologia la scienza moderna
ci ha permesso di ricostruire questa
storia e lo ha fatto in maniera
velocissima del durante gli ultimi
decenni anche grazie alla possibilità di
avere degli strumenti estremamente
sofisticati soprattutto i telescopi
spaziali che osservando l'universo dal
di fuori dell'atmosfera
permettono di raccogliere i dati che
sulla terra non arriveranno mai la luce
ultravioletta la luce infrarossa i raggi
ics i raggi gamma con tutte queste
informazioni siamo riusciti e con la
teoria della relatività generale di
einstein siamo ricostruire capaci di
ricostruire questa storia da quando
l'universo era un miscuglio in forme di
particelle elementari e di energia con
temperature ed energie che non
riusciranno mai a essere raggiunte dai
nostri laboratori terrestri e poi via
via per effetto dell'espansione globale
dello spazio la gravità la forza di
gravità ha preso il sopravvento
sull'energia delle singole particelle e
ha cominciato a creare le prime
strutture le prime stelle gli ammassi di
stelle le galassie e via via i pianeti
attorno alle stelle e all'interno delle
stelle
sostenute dalle reazioni nucleari che
avvengono al loro interno si sono
formati di elementi chimici che oggi noi
conosciamo e di cui siamo fatti
ossigeno al carbonio azoto
e il silicio fino al ferro
tutti gli atomi di ferro che in questo
momento circolano nelle nostre delle
vostre nostre vene insieme
all'emoglobina del sangue si sono
formati all'interno di una stella o
forse di altre di molte stelle che un
giorno sacrificandosi un'immane
esplosione hanno sparso nell'universo
tutti questi nuovi elementi chimici che
prima non esistevano per formare poi
pianeti e su questi pianeti far emergere
la vita
oggi sappiamo che attorno ad ogni stella
che vediamo in cielo anzi attorno ad
ogni stella dell'universo esistono
pianeti molti dei quali sono simili per
struttura le caratteristiche alla nostra
terra e quindi l'ipotesi
che anche in altre zone dell'universo
si siano sviluppate quelle condizioni
che hanno permesso l'emergere della vita
biologica e quindi poi della coscienza
come nel nostro pianeta diventa sempre
più plausibile anche se bisogna dire
subito con chiarezza
la possibilità di verificare
sperimentalmente questa ipotesi
estremamente remota ma certamente
possiamo dire ormai che un sottile filo
rosso unisce la nostra coscienza
all'evoluzione del cosmo siamo
inseparabili da questa evoluzione
allora di fronte a questa nuova
situazione
qual è la domanda fondamentale che la
nuova cosmologia ci pone
heidegger nella sua introduzione alla
metafisica
poneva questa domanda perché in generale
esiste qualcosa piuttosto che nulla e
affermava che questa era la prima e più
fondamentale di tutte le domande
ora questa si può modificare
dicendo perché ciò che esiste è
sostanzialmente evolutivo
e la differenza non è affatto banale
perché se la realtà fisica è
essenzialmente evolutiva come abbiamo
scoperto e se questa evoluzione porta
necessariamente
all'emergere della coscienza
la domanda può essere riformulata in
questo modo perché in generale esiste la
coscienza piuttosto che nulla
voi capite che
diventa sempre più impellente che la
filosofia si riavvicini alla scienza
dopo quattro secoli di separazione e la
scienza in particolare la cosmologia
deve riavvicinarsi alla filosofia per
dare un senso a quello che via via sta
scoprendo
questa separazione artificiale tra
pensiero scientifico il pensiero
umanistico deve essere ricomposta come
ai tempi gloriosi
di dante alighieri quando nel suo poema
scienza filosofia teologia arte
formavano un tutto unico un tutt'uno
bene lascio questa riflessione a voi e
torniamo ora al punto centrale di questa
serata il confine con tutte queste nuove
informazioni con questo nuovo concetto
di spazio e tempo
ha senso ancora parlare di confine
dell'universo ha senso ancora chiederci
se l'universo sia finito infinito mi
capite che se lo spazio il tempo che
definiscono i confini non possono essere
separati dalla realtà fisica e da noi
stessi quindi questa domanda perde di
significato diventa indefinita
dobbiamo allora
forse chiederci come possiamo definire
questo come possiamo
immaginare un confine oltre al quale ci
sia qualcos'altro
quando il tempo e lo spazio non
appartengono a questo qualcos'altro
perché sono legati al nostro universo
esistono forse altri universi con tempi
e spazi diversi dal nostro
oppure dobbiamo pensare immaginare una
metafisica nella quale il kronos il
tempo che scorre non esiste ma esiste
solo il kairos il tempo sacro che unisce
passato presente futuro
in effetti alcuni cosmologi per uscire
da questo dilemma subito seguito da
seguiti dai filosofi entusiasti hanno
ipotizzato i cosiddetti molti versi
innumerevoli o infiniti universi
diverse dal nostro paralleli al nostro
con i quali non potremmo però mai
entrare in comunicazione
è un'ipotesi affascinante sicuramente ma
dobbiamo subito affermare con
chiarezza
non potrà mai essere verificata
scientificamente quindi non è un'ipotesi
scientifica ma è un'ipotesi filosofica
potremmo paragonarla agli antichi miti
delle origini
il multiverso come nume helix come gill
ganesh come bere sci
di fronte a questa situazione potremmo
essere un po presi dallo sconforto nel
nel vedere che non riusciamo a stabilire
un confine ma forse riflettendo ci
accorgeremmo che questo nostro sconforto
e generato dalla dalla nostra pretesa o
illusione che il metodo scientifico sia
in grado di risolvere ogni problema che
sia in grado di conoscere tutto e invece
dobbiamo una volta di più ricordare il
manifesto galileiano rinuncio a tentar
l'essenza dobbiamo
comprendere che la realtà fisica ultima
rimarrà sempre misteriosa e quello che
noi possiamo fare invece molto più
fruttuosamente è studiare le relazioni
studiare quindi invece che studiare che
pensare al confine immaginare quale sia
la relazione nostra con l'universo
evolvente la relazione del fenomeno
umano come amava chiamarlo teilhard de
chardin e l'universo evolvente
questa è il vero confine il vero confine
forse è quello che dobbiamo analizzare è
quello tra la materia è lo spirito un
confine artificiale che ci è stato
tramandato dalla filosofia classica ma
che comincia a scricchiolare
di fronte alle nostre nuove connessioni
sul cosmo e forse va sostituito a una
graduale evoluzione
forse non siamo la stessa non siamo
differenti dalla materia il cuore della
materia come chiamava teilhard de
chardin
certamente per indagare questo nuovo
confine come abbiamo già detto non
possiamo limitarci a utilizzare il
metodo scientifico
dobbiamo umilmente riconoscere che
dobbiamo rinunciare
as conoscere tutto ma possiamo
sicuramente affidarci non solo al metodo
scientifico ma anche alla filosofia alla
poesia al mito e volendo alla teologia
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]